[موسيقى]
في اسبانيا اعتبر الخيول الاندلسيه
الاصيله كنزا لا يقدر بثمن يفتخر به
الاسبان وتراثا وطنيا يصدر للخارج بسبب
اناقتها وصفاتها الفريده الاندلس مهد
الجواد الاسبانيه الاصيل لقد تمكن مربو
الخيول من المحافظه على النسل النقي هناك
بشكل كبير على مدار قرون
هنا في مربط فونتر للخيول يتم بيع الواحد
منها بمبالغ تصل الى 20 الف دولار تقيم
بحسب نسبها الممتد عبر التاريخ
السلالات القديمه من هذه الخيول الاصيله
استخدمها حكام اوروبا لاول مره لاغراض
الحروب او الصيد لتصبح الخيول بعدها
الحيوانات المفضله للرعاه واستمرت تكاثر
عدد قليل منها في اديره الاندلس
وفي عام
1972 انشات اول مدرسه مخصصه للحصان
الاسباني وهي المدرسه الملكيه الاندلسيه
لفنون الفروسيه مدرسه عالمها مختلف برموزه
وقواعده الدقيقه وهي واحده من اكبر اربع
مدارس للفروسيه في العالم
[موسيقى]
لمده اربع سنوات ستتعلم ماريا الترويض هنا
على ايدي فرسان مخضرمين مثل رافائيل سوتو
الحائز على الميداليه الفضيه في اولمبيه
اثينا
[موسيقى]
اسبانيا
مفتوحه للجمهور وفي الكواليس يستعد رفائيل
لقياده هذا الاستعراض الذي اعتاد عليهم
منذ 25 عاما
الفرسان في هذا العرض ارتادوا ازياء من
القرن الثامن عشر لصحبه خيولهم الموهوبه
التي تقوم باداء حركات فريده او القفازات
الخاصه او الوقوف على ساقين عند الطلب
منها
البرنامج
[موسيقى]
اذا كنتم من هواه الخيول هل لديكم الشغف
للدراسه هنا يوما ما
[موسيقى]